[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تزداد وحدات
التوتر بين اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بارد
وشركات الصناعه النفط العملاقه في
الولايات المتحده قبل اقل من يومين من
اجراء الانتخابات النصفيه المقرره في
الثامن من نوفمبر الحالي وافدت وكاله
تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
ارباح شركه نفط الامريكيه الكبيره اثارت
التوترات في مجال الصناعه الوقود
واوضحتنا رئيس الامريكي من شركه النفط
الامريكيه كونها تذبحوا الانتاج لرفع
الاسعار مشهرتان لان بايظا شركه نفط
الامريكيه بيزياده الضرائب لدفعها لخط
الاسعار وكانت شركه اكسون وشثرون للنفط
حذرته من خطوره فرد بيضا اي ضرائب غير
متوقعه
[موسيقى]
الشجاعيه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن يا
دكتور غريبه الاستاذ في العلاقه الدوريه
اهلا بك دكتور ومن واشنطن عبر سكايب عباس
الباحث في شؤون الامريكيه اهلا بك دكتور
كذلك الى هذا النقاش واسمحالي ان ابدا معك
استاذ عباس في الواقعه بتهديد شركه نفط
الامريكيه بزياده الضرائب لدفعها لخفض
الاسعار هل ترى فيه حقيقه توجهها ورفقا
بالمواطن الامريكي ام ان عين بيضا على
الانتخابات ليس اكثر
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بالاستاذ العزيز ابن
غريب وبكل المشاهدين اينما كانوا لا اعتقد
انها تاتي في اطار الخوف على مكتسبات
المواطن الامريكي او على جيبه من الرئيس
جو فايدل بالطبع هي دعايه انتخابيه واضحه
قبل الانتخابات بيومين وكان امامه العديد
من الاشهر كي يقول هذه الجمله قبل ذلك
لماذا يقولها اليوم فقط لانه تم اعلان
نتائج الارباح طيب هناك اصلا يعني مؤسسات
بحثيه همم حتى منها ما هو مرتبط بالحكومه
الامريكيه يستطيع ان يحدد مكاسب هذه
الشركات بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
المندرعه منذ حوالي تقريبا 10 اشهر همم
اذا هي مساله انتخابيه همم محضه ولكن تاتي
في وقت متاخر جدا لا اعتقد ان الناخب
الامريكي سيلقي باليا لهذا الامر خاصه
بالمناسبه همم ان اسعار ال- الوقود اليوم
في ازدياد مطارد يعني في خلال الاسبوع قبل
اسبوع او حتى الان زاد جالون البرميل في
واشنطن ما يقرب من
الى 30 سنت للجالون الواحد وهذا همم يضيف
المزيد من الضغوط على جيب المواطن
الامريكي دكتور
رائد بتالي تلاعبا بنوايا العمليه
الانتخابيه وبالتالي تلاعبا بالعمليه
السياسيه باكملها في همم امريكا
همم اذا ارى الامريكيه كل الادارات
الامريكيه الا بال كل السياسيين الله
يبارك فيك يستغلوا اوضاع معينه على تحقيق
اهداف سياسيه همم هذا ليس جديد ولكن
الرئيس فعلا
الهجوم قبل تقريبا اسبوع طبعا كان قبل اما
الى ذلك عده مرات قبل ذلك ولكن هل الهجمات
بدات حوالي قبل اسبوع عندما برزت معلومات
تفيد بان الارباح همم ارباح شركات النفط
والغاز وخاصه شركات الكبرى قد وصلت الى
ارقام قياسيه فعلا همم
خلال الربع الاول والثاني والان الثالث
همم هذا العام انها قد ارتفعت الاسعار
كمان اعلم جميعا اسعار البنزين اسعار
النفط عبر النفط وصلت في مرحله من المراحل
الى 140 دولار للبرميل وبالتالي فان هذه
الارباح وصلت حسب بعض ال- اا المعلومات
الى حوالي 200 مليون دولار
حتى اختفى ولذلك فان الرئيس وهو يواجه
تحديات كبيره الان اا تحديات انتخابيه
وهنا اتفقت تماما ما قاله
صديقي العزيز للاستاذ عباس وان هذه
الاداره تحاول همم ان تحقق اهداف سياسيه
بشان هجمات على شركات النفط وذلك هل فعلا
لانها تعتقد بان شركات النفط التي حققت
ارباح حاضر قياسيه غير يعني غير متوقعه
همم
يمكن على الاقل ان يستغلها الرئيس لتحقيق
اهداف سياسيه وربما لكسب اصوات همم بعض
الاميركيين الامريكي
من الغريب اعتبار ذلك مشروعا كما تفضلت
بالاشاره قد يقول الدكتور ايهاب بانه هذا
لا يموت لشيء من شرعيه الانتخابات دكتور
عباس همم ما رايك لانه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
كل شيء بحسابه حتى الكلام والوعود خاصه
لها حسابات اذا لم تنفذ فيما بعد
حضرتك يجب ان نشير هنا ايضا الى ان الرئيس
جو بيض على اعداء اصلا مع قطاع النفط داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي خلال دعايته الانتخابيه للرئاسه
الماضيه يعني قبل عامين واكثر بقليل كانت
تقوم هذه الدعايه في احد بنودها على
استبدال الطاقه الاحفوريه اليوم التي
تستخدم يعني النفط والمحروقات الى اخره
الطاقه النظيفه والمتجدده والطاقه الشمسيه
الى اخره وهناك تهديدات كانت من قبله ومن
قبل حملته بانه سيحاول القضاء على القطاع
النفطي
يعني بحلول عام 2050 على ما اتذكر او 60
شيء من هذا القبيل يعني هو يقصد الرجل انه
يريد ان يحاول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للاعتماد على الطاقه النظيفه والطاقه
المتجدده وليس الطاقه التي تزيد من تضرر
المناخ نتفق معه في ذلك الامر ولكن لا
تعادي هذا القطاع الكبيره الذي يبلغ
العاملون همم فيه همم واساره والقطاعات
المرتبطه به ما يقرب من حوالي 10 ملايين
او خمسه عشره مليون مواطن امريكي فهؤلاء
كلهم اصواتهم دائما وابدا تذهب الى
الجمهوريين لذلك هذا العداء الجديد لهذه
الشركات اليوم ما من شانه الا ان يزيد من
اصرار الناخب الجمهوري الا الى التوجه الى
صناديق الاقتراع وليس عدم التصويت ولكن
للتصويت لكل من هو جمهوري على حساب
الديمقراطيه
نظيفه تعلم حضرتك بان اطلق النظيفه يعمل
على وسائل تحقيقها لسنوات طويله وليس
لسنتين
بالضبط حتى وان وضع خطه لن تكفيه سنتان
لتحقيق هذه الخطه دكتور ادم هل باقي له
غير الكلام غير الوعود لمحاوله الظفر ببعض
القبول في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه لانه
نرى بانه لم يتبقى له شيء حتى الامريكيون
همم يعني همم اعلن غضبهم وقالوا نحن من
اوصلنا انفسنا لما نعيشه اليوم همم يعني
فيما يتعلق بغلاء المعيشه
بايرن يجد نفسه الان في وضع صعب
والديمقراطيين ايضا في وضع صعب ااه هناك
توقعات كبيران او سيخسروا مجلس النواب
وهناك احتمال بان يسيطر الجمهوريون ايضا
على مجلس الشيوخ ولذلك نرى هذه
الانتخابيه التي يقوم بها الرئيس يقوم بها
الرئيس السابق اوباما يقوم بها همم
الديمقراطيين المعروفين والعيبه الرايس
وحتى هيلاري كلينتون واخرين وذلك لانهم
يخشون نتائج هذه
الانتخابات طبعا هذه قد تكون احنا الاسلحه
التي يستغلها الرئيس ليقول ان ارتفاع
الاسعار ارتفاع اسعار البنزين وهي مشكله
كبيره بالنسبه للمواطن الامريكي نتيجه
الواقعيه التي تحققها شركات النفط وهدد
شركات النفط بانه سوف يفرض عقوبات عليها
صعب ولكن في نفس الوقت هذه مساله صعبه
وخاصه ان شركات النفط كانت تعاني مثلا
اسهم شركه اكسون موبل قبل ثلاث سنوات وصلت
الى حوالي 30 دولار للسهم الان هي 112
دولار ولماذا لم يساعد همم تساعد الاداره
هذه الشركه عندما كانت تواجه مشاكل كبيره
وبدات تبيع ارسلتها هذا يعني وخاصه في
السوق في السوق الراس التي التي تؤمن به
الادارات الامريكيه بغض النظر كانت
جمهوريه اوديمقراطيه ولذلك اعتقد ان هناك
مشكله كبيره تواجهه ديموقراطيين والرئيس
يحاول ان يتخطى هذه المشكله وان ينسب همم
في السوق اذا سياسته
سياسه في المدرسه
هل ستنجح هذه المره هذه الخطه دكتور ايهاب
هل يمكن القول هذه هي رقصه الديك المذبوح
ام هناك مبالغه في قول ذلك وبان
الديمقراطيين امم لديهم القدره همم من
الاستفاده من هذه الاجراءات الاخيره
المذبوحه اتفق مع حضرتك في هذا التعبير
واا يعني هناك من سخريات القادر يعني جو
بايدن الذي همم
كان يحاول منذ اشهر قليل جدا مع عده دول
الخليجيه همم كي تقوم برفع انتاجها من
النفط همم تربيه همم لما يعتقد هو
احتياجات الاسواق العالميه لخفض اسعار
النفط اليوم لا يستطيع اصلا ان يتحكم في
انتاج النفط الداخلي في بلاده ولا في هذه
الشركات
ويخالف كل التوقعات السوقيه يعني اتفق مع
دكتور ادمن فيما يتعلق بمعانات شركات
النفط الامريكيه خلال الفتره الماضيه خاصه
همم كورونا لان همم انتاج برميل النفط
الذي يستخرج مثلا من خام تكساس من من
الصخر يتكلف تقريبا حوالي 35 او ل 40
دولار همم التكلفه الانتاج وكان يباع ابان
كرونه بثمانيه 28$ الشركات كانت تخصى ب
عشرات ومئات الملايين من الدولارات ولم
يتدخل جو بايدن لحمايه هذه الشركات فمن حق
هذه الشركات اليوم ان تحقق ارباحها بكل
تاكيد وهو عليه اداره سياساته الخارجيه
بصوره انجع كي ينخفض سعر البترول المساله
ليست في ارباح قياسيه لشركات البترول
الداخليه المساله في سوء ادارته للملفات
الخارجيه التي ادت بارتفاع اسعار النفط
بهذه الصوره الغريبه
الامور ان ستفعل هذا التهديدات ام لا هو
انفعالات كيف سيكون همم تكون ترجيها على
حسب الديمقراطيين اود شكرا لكم جزيلا شكرا
على الحضور ومشاركتنا هذا النقاش من وعشان
ايهاب عباس البحث في شؤون الامريكيه
كذلك الدكتور غريبه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]